ja soweit die Präsidenten Netanyahu und
beiden heute in Israel über die aktuelle
Situation in naost kann ich nun sprechen
mit dem naostexerten Michael Lüders
guten Abend Herr
Lüders schön guten Abend hallo Sie haben
ja auch gerade diesen Ausschnitt aus der
Pressekonferenz mitverfolgen können
Biden und Netanyahu interessant fand ich
dass Joe Biden der amerikanische
Präsident eine maßvolle Reaktion anmahnt
Richtung Israel ist denn diese Forderung
gerechtfertigt haben Sie den Eindruck
dass das maßlos ist was da im Moment von
Israel
kommt na ja wenn man sich die
Entwicklung im Gazastreifen anguckt in
den letzten Tagen 1,1 Millionen Menschen
die gezwungen werden vom Norden in den
Süden des Gazastreifens zu flüchten weil
sie nur dort angeblich in Sicherheit
sein das ist schon jenseits jedem jedem
internationalen Strafrechtes das geht
viel zu weit wird aber von der
westlichen Politik offenbar akzeptiert
und das ist nicht gut denn man kann in
diesen Konflikt zwischen Israel und den
Palästinensern nicht militärisch lösen
es gibt nur eine politische Lösung auch
wenn es im Augenblick danach natürlich
nicht aussieht kurze Erinnerung Herr
lüdus 1400 Menschen sind ermordet worden
teils bestialisch abgeschlachtet worden
auf deutsch gesagt da ist es doch
verständlich dass Israel jetzt versucht
die Hammers zu zerschlagen
oder vieles mag verständlich sein aber
ich glaube man muss unterscheiden
zwischen moralischer empphase und
nüchterner Analyse und zur nüchternen
Analyse gehört natürlich auch dass man
die faktenlag nüchtern betrachtet und
sorgfältig abwgt was man sagt oder was
man nicht sagt wir haben eben im Beitrag
gehört dass es doch mittlerweile als
erwiesen gelten soll dass die
Palästinenser selber diese Rakete
abgefeuert haben die das Krankenhaus
zerstört hat das alahli Krankenhaus in
Gaza es ist aber interessant darauf zu
verweisen dass gestern ein Sprecher der
israelischen Armee Hanan Naftali die
folgende Botschaft verbreitete über
Twitter x breaking die israelische
Luftwaffe hat soeben eine Terrorbasis
der Hamas in einem Krankenhaus in Gaza
getroffen zahlreiche Terroristen sind
getötet es bricht einem das Herz dass
die Hamas Raketen abschießt aus
Krankenhäusern mcheenschulen und dabei
Menschen als Schutzschilde benutzt das
war 2 Minuten zu lesen auf Ex und
Twitter danach wurde es gelöscht
anschließend sagte die israelische Armee
dass der islamische jahad dafür
verantwortlich war und die Beweise die
man dafür vorgelegt hatte sind
mittlerweile auch nicht mehr im Netz zu
finden ja Herr L jetzt kommen sie mit
mit solchen ohtönen ich könnte mit
anderen ohtönen von der anderen Seite
kommen die das israelische Militär heute
veröffentlicht hat ich glaube das führt
zu nichts es ist sowieso keine
unabhängige internationale Untersuchung
jetzt möglich deshalb würde ich wenn Sie
einverstanden sind lieber sozusagen
etwas übergeordneter fragen weil vorhin
die Meldung kam dass Iran die arabische
Welt auffordert mit Israel zu brechen
wie stehen denn die Chancen des
Terrorregimes in Tehran dass es dafür
Gehör
findet
ich würde vorschlagen dass man Dinge
nüchternd und sachlich analysiert in
moralisierender Hinsicht sind wir
natürlich alle empört über den Iran und
über andere Akteure in der Region aber
wir sollten doch die Augen nicht daavor
verschließen dass das was hier dort
passiert durchaus in einer größeren
Katastrophe münden kann ind dem
beispielsweise die Hisbollah involviert
wird indem Israel und oder die USA auf
die Idee kommen könnten den Iran
anzugreifen man sollte sich davor
darüber im Klaren sein dass dieses dann
der auftagt wäre zu einer brutalen
Auseinandersetzung zu einem Krieg an dem
gemessen der Krieg in der Ukraine fast
wie eine harmloses Gemetzel anmutet es
ist eine äußerst gefährliche Situation
Politik ist gefragt diplomatie ist
gefragt und es bedarf eben auch einer
sorgfältigen Prüfung gegebener Fakten
sonst macht man sich zum Propagandisten
von
Kriegsparteien Stichwort flechtenbrand
Herr lydis was glauben sie w hätte das
größte Interesse in der Region einen
solchen Flächenbrand
auszulösen
ich denke dass niemand der bei Verstand
ist ein Interesse daran haben kann einen
Flächenbrand auszulösen ich denke das
Problem in der Region dass wir haben das
ist dass die palästinafage seit 1967
nicht gelöst worden ist Israel führt ein
Besatzungsregime über eine
millionenschar von Palästinensern im
Westjordanland im Gazastreifen die
westlichen Staaten haben es akzeptiert
dass dieses Unrecht seit Jahrzehnten
andauert und es ist wie Gideon haretz
wie Gideon Levi von der Zeitung haretz
gesagt hat schon sehr erstaunlich wenn
man glaubt dass man so viele Menschen
unterdrücken könnne ohne dass es
irgendwann zu einer gewaltigen Explosion
kommt solange diese palästinerfage nicht
gelöst wird wird es immer wieder Zyklen
der Gewalt geben und wenn man das
wirklich beenden will dann muss man auch
die Freundin Israel in die Pflicht
nehmen und ihnen sagen ja wir sind an
eurer Seite in Israel aber wir stehen
nicht auf der Seite eines ultrarechten
einer ultrarechten israelischen
Regierung die kein Interesse daran hat
sich mit den Nachbarn ins Benehmen zu
setzen mit den Palästinensern irgendwie
eine Regelung zu finden die zwei
staatenlösung ist in weiter Ferne und
die Region steht vor einer gewaltigen
Explosion sagt Michael Lüder Denner
ostexperte ich sage vielen Dank für Ihre
Zeit